driss galy bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
le disait malgré un pays très durement
touchée par le coni gianni molinaro
compte 40% d'opinions favorables alors
qu'il était à 25% dans la crise
finalement son choix de ne pas confiner
le pays lui est il était favorable
je pense bonsoir d'abord je pense que
oui puisque il a ça lui a permis de
parler à des classes populaires qui
réellement ressentie dans leur chair
prix 1 le prix du blocage du blocage de
l'économie parce que le brésil n'a pas
confiné mais les mairies n'ont pas suivi
par sonar ou j'habite açores par où
l'amérique soit par l'eau qui est plutôt
au centre gauche a fait une sorte de
blocage de l'économie en fermant les
bars on les autorisons ouvrir pendant
quelques heures
les écoles sont encore fermées donc on
dit que le brésil n'a pas confiné mais
en fait il ya eu beaucoup d' entrave à
la circulation et les plus les gens qui
lui donne à fromelles et des femmes de
ménage les gardiens des vigiles sa pays
qu'il est passionné le cas beaucoup de
vigiles les gens qui travaillent dans
les supermarchés ils ont vu qu'ils ont
perdu leur job il ce matin julien alors
faut supermarché puisque j'avais vu que
je n'ai jamais vu en dix ans au brésil
une file d'attenté mais 20 30 personnes
pour remettre des cv pour gagner un smic
qui aussi autour de même pas 200 250
euros une file d'attenté trad pour être
dans un supermarché
c'est dire la détresse de ce peuple
effectivement ball sont araud a été un
des rares à leur dire votre jeu
m'intéresse ou pain quotidien et je
préfère que vous
voilà limites que vous exposez vos vite
que mourir de faim etc les gens ça
s'apprend par s'apprend pas chez les
classes moyennes supérieures qui
travaillent en remote office santé
travail qui sont assurés d'avoir un
salaire par les multinationales résider
à nos internationales mais chez le
peuple qui est le plus nombreux à ses
copains qui est en bas de la pyramide et
qui est le plus nombreux donc d'un point
de vue électoral qui est très important
ce soir on a marqué des points alors il
ya eu aussi un ce versement d'une aide
financière de 100 à 200 euros aux plus
pauvres
est-ce que là aussi ça a permis de
limiter la crise est-ce que d'autres
facteurs ont permis ce rebond de
popularité du président brésilien
alors le prophète il y a deux brésil
d'un point de vue électoral il ya le
brésil de l'accent paulo rio où se passe
l'économie des signaux se passe la vie
on va dire économique de dans ce pays
ce cet axe là voter pour son art au même
chez les plus pour d'être j'allais dire
même surtout chez les plus pauvres pour
des raisons évangéliques pour des
raisons de lutte contre l'insécurité
savez c'est comme en france c'est les
plus pauvres qui se font massacrer et
les riches normalement ils vivent dans
des ghettos parisien où il
ils ont tendance à excuser télé les
crimes il est alors aisé à peu près
pareil donc les pauvres paient des axes
de l'actrice au sort par l'eau votée par
ceux de lax d'une horde est c'est à dire
les états où on va en vacances d'adhérer
fortaleza fin de la table un dodge
bailly a qui sont des états très
peuplées mais 30 % des brésiliens caisse
pour cent du pid 30% du brésil annonce
en ce sens des états pauvres c est à la
voter majoritairement lula parce que
c'était la gauche c'était le petit père
du peuple et nous la distribuer la bolsa
familia quitter une allocation
permanente une sorte de rsa et la mosson
arrow grâce ou à cause du gros vide et
aura mis une humaine s'appelle maxi de
américiane l'aide du
gensse et et malheureusement c'est
dommage pour la démocratie mais ce ces
gens là ont commencé à porter par
d'ambon sauna rôle sauveur ils sont en
train de remplacer l'icône de lula celle
que nous adorons france parce qu'il est
de gauche par l'icône de bolton arrow
qui distribue les 100 euros par mois je
vous dis que c'est dommage moi
démocratie parce que c'est ça veut dire
qu'on se sent des voix qu'on achète
mais voilà c'est la réponse à votre
question la flandre al ghanim lord est
énorme mais c'est 30% population
brésilienne
donc effectivement pour une réélection
il est beaucoup moins enfin ça s'annonce
pas trop mal vous parlez également deux
fois on sait que cette notion de fois
elle est très présente au brésil
girveau le scénario a survécu à une
attaque au couteau puis au coville est
ce que le président brésilien son parent
du religieux comme ressort pour unir son
peuple autour de lui disons que le il
faut pas exagérer leur foi au brésil
disons-nous le brésil est un pays
occidental nous l'oublions souvent mais
ici c'est l'occident et donc nous avons
les mêmes maladies entre guillemets que
l'occident que la france ou l'europe
il ya une très forte et à la mort du
code à bulles de catholicisme et
l'église s'effondrent les églises
catholiques se vide et une partie
seulement une partie est récupéré par
les évangélistes qui sont les amis de
beausobre sa femme et évangéliste lui
les catholiques mais très proche du
nombre magique de ce qui se passe au
fait donc la fois au brésil
elle n'est pas aussi frais et dépenses
il forte que ça ce que ce que par contre
bolton araud a résumé et incarne c'est à
dire c'est qu'il t'a le sait que c'est
branché sur le bon sens populaire il est
il a compris le qu'il ya aujourd'hui
deux types de deux fois qu'il a eu c'est
ce qu'assure de doctorat société entre
les gens qui sont qui peuvent vivre qui
peuvent traverser le pot vide à la
maison henri rod office et ceux qui
peuvent qu ils ne peuvent pas s'empêcher
de de sortir de chez eux donc je pense
pas qu'il faille exagéré l'aspect de la
la fois religieux c'est plus une âme il
a une connexion avec des classes
populaires qui sont souvent vilipendé
dans les médias qui sont ces les pauvres
cons en france qu'on appelle lé beau
félin lui il leur part et ils sont
nombreux entre guillemets donc c'est ce
qui à mon avis va lui
l'uefa lui amener des troupes électoral
plus en plus nombreuses alors justement
cette popularité chez ces classes là
est-ce que d'un point de vue économique
on peut penser que jaillir ball sonar ou
taxe les riches pour relancer l'économie
on verra ce que va faire son minutes de
l'économie par le guen ce qui est
d'abord un spécialiste de les brebis
parce que pour son art au stade
militaire et qu'ils étaient formés en
profitèrent prof d'éducation physique
dans l'armée un boxer c'est pas un biais
d'économies alors que monsieur par le ps
est très fort ça libérale et pro de
chicago lui il veut libéraliser
l'économie
il lui la momie dont 12 % de déficit du
pib cette année à distribuer des repas
pour opib l'idée c'est de créer des
nouveaux impôts
une façon les riches au brésil sont pas
très taxée et la taxation président est
très injuste surtout pour le capital le
brésil un pays où les dividendes sont
pas sont pas très taxée donc il ya une
réforme
l'app est tributaire de fiscale qui
pistent active even au parlement on sait
pas au fait la réponse à votre question
c'est que derrière en coulisse
aujourd'hui il ya ya ya ya ya des
négociations parce qu'on a le premier
donné un coup de pouce à voir en termes
de popularité
et même là le l'opposition se dit des
négociations pour un second mandat il
peut envisager un second mode âge
ailleurs bolsenheim
pour conclure oui clairement enfin on
sait pas dans deux ans ce pas ce qui va
se passer
moi je pense qu'il est bien parti parce
que 40 % de popularité de noailles à 30
% de gens qui votent gauche hoarau par
conviction parce que ce sont des
religieux parce que ce sont des gens qui
détestent la roche donc 30% de sobres
électorale fixe est énorme
à deux ans des élections mais auquel je
fais référence et avec l'opposition
avec les gens doutent depuis
centre-gauche qui faisait la guerre à la
rocky qui faisait d'eux qui l'entravé au
niveau du parlement ne votant pas les
les mois passent au tapis
parlementariste ici le au brésil ils
sont en train de négocier pour à la
limite qui leur donne des postes
ministériels et des députés secrétariat
et qu' il le laisse faire ces réformes
économiques dont c'est la fiscalité
donc peut-être qu'on est en train de le
voir un bol sonar au nouveau qui va
paraître être un peu plus consensuel
parce qu'il va devoir faire des
alliances c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle je trouve pour le brésil de
voir que le pays redevienne ouvert merci
beaucoup
driss ghali pour vos précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste en
relations internationales